mme assurons l'accueil en plateau john
allan walsh notre grand reporter bonjour
de la tonne merci d'être là puisque vous
revenez tout juste d'ukraine du dombass
pour france 24 on parlait à l'instant de
l'iscid chance que vous avez rencontrés
là-bas des habitants qui ont décidé de
rester malgré les combats malgré les
violences vous retenez quoi de cette
journée de tournage passé avec eux
d'abord le la souffrance terrible de la
population et la terreur dans laquelle
ils vivaient déjà à l'époque si je puis
dire parce qu'on y était il ya une
semaine avec camara la médaille oui donc
cette ville de licite chance qu encore
une fois elle est l bord de severodonezk
y est aujourd'hui l'objet d'intenses
combats qui est qui est bombardée sans
arrêt et il ya seulement un fleuve le
fleuve d'eau nièce qui sépare ces deux
villes à l'époque déjà il y avait aussi
des bombardements très fort sur la ville
de licite chance qu aujourd'hui la
situation s'est encore aggravée
je vous propose de regarder un petit
extrait du reportage que nous avions que
nous avions fait à l'époque et qui donne
je pense une idée de ce qu endurent
aujourd'hui cette population
une vie sans eau potable
et l'électricité
l'aide humanitaire est devenue le seul
recours
je suis venu chercher de l'eau pour
pouvoir me laver c'est de l'eau non
potable mais dieu merci au nom nasa et
pour l'eau potable en fait comment il se
sert des puits
à l'ouest la ville voisine de
severodonezk est presque totalement
encerclée par l'armée russe
[Musique]
les forces du craignent n font tout pour
défendre ce verrou stratégique
est licite chante ce qui est pris entre
deux feux
vie sur la ligne de front ça tire dans
tous les sens ou dessus de nos têtes on
ne peut rien faire d'autre que s'en
remettre à dieu
voilà c'est juste un bref un bref aperçu
mais je garde en tête ce qu'on vient de
voir l'instant ses interviews qu'on a
fait de cette habitante de licite chance
qui est qu'ils étaient systématiquement
interrompu par des tirs d'artillerie
tout proche et convoyait sursauter à
chaque fois voilà cette femme cette
femme traumatisée par ces bombardements
permanence et c'était une des images
marquantes pour nous de notre tournage
sur place vous avez aussi tourné aux
côtés de combattants étrangers qui eux
ont rejoint l'armée ukrainienne est ce
qu'on l'a une estimation du nombre de
ses combattants étrangers aujourd'hui en
ukraine alors une estimation sérieuses
n'ont en tout cas la communication de
guerre ukrainienne il faut voilà il faut
être un petit peu prudent avec les
chiffres qui sont annoncés tout au début
de l'invasion russe les autorités
ukrainiennes parler d'une légion
internationale avec jusqu'à vingt mille
20 mille membres en tout cas 20000
personnes prêtes à combattre en ukraine
jeu j'ai personnellement le sentiment
qu'on est très loin de ce chiffre mais
on rencontre effectivement
beaucoup de combattants étrangers sur
les lignes de front dans l'est de
l'ukraine et nous avons donc rencontré
ce sont les images qu'on voit qu'on voit
derrière moi un groupe d'une trentaine
de combattants étrangers qui venaient
d'un peu partout en amérique du nord
amérique latine en europe y avait un
français de l'ouest de la france et ses
combattants avaient tous un peu la même
manière d'expliquer leurs motivations et
les raisons pour lesquelles ils sont ils
sont venus combattre en ukraine il n'en
pouvait plus de voir les informations à
la télé de voir les morts à la télé de
voir le sort que subissent et le peuple
ukrainien l'armée ukrainienne et il
avait il sentait cette envie aux tripes
de faire quelque chose d' intervenir
tous ne voulait pas intervenir avec les
armes forcément on a rencontré notamment
un belge qui a d'abord fait de
l'humanitaire en pologne pour aider les
réfugiés et puis après quelques semaines
il a décidé il a décidé de prendre les
armes et de rejoindre de rejoindre
l'armée ukrainienne est donc cette unité
que nous avons rencontrés dans le cadre
d'un reportage d'un tournage elle avait
été intégrée officiellement à la garde
nationale ukrainienne je vous propose là
encore de regarder un court extrait et
d'écouter deux des témoignages que nous
avons recueillis ce jour là
le président ukrainien a donné son
accord il a demandé à tous les étrangers
prêts à se battre venir aider l'ukraine
j'ai fait trois ans dans les forces
armées canadiennes en tant que soldat
d'infanterie je suis parti
pendant environ deux semaines ce n'était
pas la première ligne quand il était un
petit peu plus en arrière mais il y
avait il y avait de l'action
wes et de combattants étaient été en
l'occurrence canadien une pensée aussi
de nate henn à notre confrère le corps
de frédéric leclerc qui a été donc
rapatrié en france journaliste de bfm tv
tués
alors qu'ils tournaient un reportage il
y a deux semaines c'était en l'ukraine
dans le donbass victime d'un d'un éclat
d'obus
vous l'aviez croisés c'est l'occasion
aussi pour nous pour vous de dire à quel
point ce métier est dangereux notamment
ici en zone de guerre oui et dans une
zone de guerre de 2,1 haute intensité
comme les comme l'est aujourd'hui le
dombass avec eux ces bombardements
convient d'évoquer ses tirs d'artillerie
la route qui a été emprunté le jour de
sa mort par frédéric leclerc imhoff et
par maxime brandstetter et leur fixaient
roxana qui ont pour l'heure pas survécu
à cette à ce bombardement nous avions
emprunté la même route la veille pour
nous rendre au même endroit les sites
chance qu'on l'a mentionné tout à
l'heure et c'est une c'est une route qui
qui longe des positions des deux camps
en fait qui se trouve entre les
positions d'artillerie ukrainiennes et
russes et tout le long de cette route on
peut voir des panaches de fumée un peu
partout on peut entendre c'est très
sonore aussi on les entend ces tirs
d'artillerie pour notre part nous étions
dans un véhicule qui allait très vite
c'est une des une des règles de sécurité
on va dire à maintenir quand on est
quand on est sur ces routes vraiment
vraiment dangereuse frédéric leclerc
imhoff était pour sa part dans un dans
un camion blindé qui se rendait à licite
chance pour pour sauver des gens qui
habitaient là bas pour les pour les
emmener ailleurs dans le dans le donbass
est un peu plus un peu plus à l'ouest et
puis voilà ils ont été le camion a été
frappée a été frappé par par un
bombardement on ne saura sans doute
jamais si ce bombardement était
volontaire ou involontaire mais en tout
cas
moi comme je pense toute la profession
j'ai une pensée émue pour
évidemment d'abord pour lui pour
frédéric mais aussi pour son pour son
collègue maxime brandstetter qui a qui a
survécu à l'attaqué puis pour l'heure
fixeuse oksana qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui sain et sauf et qui sont
rentrés en france il y aura un hommage
vendredi à 18h30 à paris et place de la
république en hommage à frédéric
e.leclerc imhoff à l'appel de reporters
sans frontières et merci pour votre
témoignage pour travailler votre
engagement de nat and wolf tous les
reportages sont bien sûr à retrouver sur
notre site france24 point com merci
encore merci